former Vice President Joe Biden says
wearing a mask should be seen as
patriotic it's a word he used at a town
hall last night he says he's glad that
President Trump appears to be recovering
but he also said the president does bear
some responsibility for getting sick in
the first place and he blasted Mr Trump
for the message that he's sending to
others Ed o'keef has more on this part
of the story from
Washington speaking to South Florida
voters last night Joe Biden once again
sent best wishes to the first family but
said he isn't surprised by the president
illness anybody who contracts the virus
by essentially saying Mass don't matter
social distancing doesn't
matter I I think is is is responsible
for what happens to them shortly after
the president took off his mask while
re-entering the White House Biden
implored Americans to keep them on now
what is this Macho thing I'm not going
to wear a mask what's the deal here big
deal does it hurt you be patriotic for
God's sake take care of yourself but
take care of your neighbors that stay
care is a presid the former vice
president said he isn't worried about
Contracting the virus despite being in
the same room as Mr Trump a week ago no
because look I've been fastidious about
the social distancing I've been
fastidious about wearing a mask when I'm
not socially distanced and even then
remaining social distance and so we
never got closer than you and I are
right now earlier in the day his wife
Jill had to step in to remind him to
keep a social distance from
reporters I'm sorry in his first visit
to South Florida since becoming the
Democratic Presidential nominee Biden
also visited the Little Haiti and Little
Havana neighborhoods hoping to increase
black and Latino support and he said
he's ready to debate the president again
if doctors say it's safe to do so but
admitted their first meeting didn't go
as he'd hoped I think it was
embarrassing for the nation to see the
president of United States just
hectoring like you did
now remember there is another debate
tomorrow night between vice president
Mike Pence and Biden running mate
California Senator kamla Harris the
commission on presidential debate say
they will be divided 12 ft 3 in and with
plexiglass dividing them as a precaution
meanwhile president Trump and the Biden
campaign say they're preparing for the
October 15th debate in Miami but Anthony
we expect negotiations over exactly how
that will happen to continue in the
coming days all right Ed thank you